friedrich es ist zeit für veränderung
und mit morgen darüber man als vater und
möchte hier faktor sie klar
lösungsvorschlags umgesetzt wird und es
ist es die politik muss das einfach
umsetzen also kein verständnis dafür
dass ich mich für politik im alter in
interessiert und ich halte was ich so
erbringen thema wie kann man sich ein
leben passieren mir in der schlange ein
reserviertes machen um ihr werdet wieder
im insistieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind die schülerinnen und schüler
die die klimadiskussion in der schweiz
vorantreiben
an einer zweitägigen konferenz vor zwei
wochen haben sie den internationalen
streiktag vom 15
märz geplant und gemeinsam geklärt wie
sie sich zur institutionellen politik
stellen wollen eine unabhängige
politische bewegung entsprechend keine
wahlempfehlungen aus sprich unterstützen
kleine parteien und keine personen gibt
es einen konsens zu dieser
medienmitteilung
ich denke dass manches bewegt das ziel
das meer schon mal gehört wurde sind
dann könnte das ich erreicht wurde
dass freunde gespielt wurde sind das
definitiv nicht aber ich denke mein gott
international vor allem auch haben ihre
unglaublich beweglich keine aufbau und
sind nur noch draußen sind wir erst am
anfang und und das ist danke dass sie
dem wave ist es unglaublich
euro
wir blenden zurück es ist ende januar
jonas janina und jonathan sind auf dem
weg nach davos
die drei schüler aus wetzikon wollen am
wef für den klimaschutz demonstrieren
jonas muss noch texten
klimakrise österreicher ohne brutal
stehen und immer härter
wir sind momentan gerade dreht schiffes
weg ich bin gestellt auch die arabica
gedeckt wurde zum geschrieben
wir sind 160 meter und hat die retouren
slot wir also halt reserviert für dreht
und sozial nicht und wenn halt trotzdem
personen wie how und hans michel spontan
am drücker genau
[Musik]
am tag zuvor ist die 16-jährige greta
team berg in der bus angekommen
empfangen wurde sie wie ein star mit
ihrer rede an der klimakonferenz von
kattowitz hat die junge schwedin viele
jugendliche aufgerüstet
und eine dynamik in die klimadiskussion
gebracht wie sie niemand erwartet hätte
greta spricht aus was viele denken und
die jungen schon lange beschäftigt im
dezember haben sich etwa hundert
schülerinnen und schüler in der schweiz
zu einem mozart zusammengeschlossen um
aktiv etwas gegen die klimaerwärmung zu
tun
aus dem wortschatz ist mittlerweile eine
nationale klima bewegung geworden die
demo in davos hat die user organisiert
jonas ist seit letztem sommer mitglied
und kennt fast alle hier überall in der
schweiz haben sich jugendliche
organisiert an einem sonntagnachmittag
findet eine sitzung der basler klima
gruppe statt
die flyer für die geplante nationale
demo vom 2
februar sind da
ich bin mega stars papier ist geschlagen
unsere mega diskussion nele und ihre
freundin pauline sind im komitee an
vorderster front dabei politisch aktiv
waren die beiden bisher nicht im tschad
die erwartung auf um sie etwas
zufälliges nachts rüberkommt und sind
jetzt haben sie hinter den exeo
unternehmen innerhalb europas ohne sind
blätter 52 wird den xxl geburtstags ist
es aber ganz und der reise eine
versprüht jede passiert als der regen ab
dieser drei musketiere und jetzt
passiert ist und dann zu einer mega viel
liter pils und so und dann sind
plötzlich immer größer wurde und der
hand haben können die demo andere das
aufgenommene funke so aber wir alle
haben alle haben sie wähle mache aber
keiner hat so wenn sie sage und dann
hätten wir es irgendwie auch mal gemacht
und eine ich so losgegangen und alles im
sommer die wir klären das ist so viel
freude und energie an deinem ganzen weg
sehr geschmackvoll pauline informiert
was auf nationaler ebene beschlossen
wurde
hamburg waldsee an nationalen und meint
es ist einfach so um die organisation
gange wir uns bewegen organisieren und
sich halt um die grundsatzdiskussion ist
nicht ob die grundsatzdiskussion
entschieden wurde in bern auch was man
als nächstes plant 15
märz wird international ein taxi wo
wirklich nutzen die lande
gleichzeitig wahrten mitmachen und das
ist mega international vernetzt also die
haben da gibt es national gibt es alles
gute was kommt das kümmert und die sind
jetzt mit extrem vielen
die hypo carbon nach berlin reiste schon
recht alte hat für uns dass die yamaha
kontakt mit zum beispiel deutschland
die bewegung macht druck in alle
richtungen
nele mahnt aber auch selbst mit gutem
beispiel voranzugehen
ich bin einfach zu sagen mit der nummer
in der politik nämlich bei uns auch wenn
wir uns auf den sie mir mega
unglaubwürdig und eine kaffeekasse dass
man probiert viele jugendliche fühlen
sich von den erwachsenen nicht ernst
genommen gerade bei micro
unterschriftensammler da jetzt viele
weitere services gmbh feric also ich
kann dir jetzt feilt funktioniert das
finde ich schwierigkeit und das hat
jetzt die möglichkeit gab es ganz viele
jugendliche zusammengeschlossen und
plötzlich wieder alle tragen sich in
arbeitsgruppen ein damit nicht zu viel
arbeit auf ein paar wenigen lastet
bolligen im kanton bern
hier wohnt nina mit ihren eltern
fleisch findet man auf der pizza in
diesem haushalt selten
[Musik]
damit kommt nicht wo mir dass wir nicht
das hat natürlich auch mit mir zu tun
mit drei wurde sie vegetarierin
mit 15 war sie zum ersten mal an einer
damned und seit dezember ist sie im
organisationskomitee der berner klima
streikenden im letzten herbst aber war
sie noch in marokko in den ferien
sie bewege ich eine short letzten stoß
okay sagt jetzt konsequent und wirkt so
viel mehr sachen konsequenten 8
also wenn ich total nass machen die
familie nicht sagen
politik.de sache diskutiert der großteil
vom nicht verflogen ist und das ist ein
mann mit viel humor zum stehen und nicht
explizit verzichten
das heißt nicht dass neue stoffe und
klar ich will ich perfekt aber das ist
sicherlich das überleben
die erzeugung um die ohren haben und es
wird neben fall mehrheit funktioniere
als frucht hat sondern es braucht ein
gesicht
es braucht 65 aber das kann ihn immer
dass sie es muss ganz klar lösungen für
politiker lila und pauline bereiten sich
auf die schweizweite klima demo vom
samstag vor
die karton plakate aus recyclingmaterial
sind das typische erkennungszeichen des
klima streiks was steht drauf und ich
habe ihn mir ganz stark gezeichnet so
wenn alle und denner und eine person das
leben so folgt mir feiern das gelernt so
voll kraft
der schweizer wird für taxi wenig ganz
klar auch wenn nicht unterschätzen kann
froh sein wenn man da so wackelt
sie sollten eigentlich nur mehr könne
mache woodley klose ja tatsächlich
bringen sie so immer mehr leute auf die
straße auch wenn sie nicht alle die
gleiche weltanschauung haben besitzen
ein hardcore kommunisten und der
hardcore mit komische und in haiti sind
bürgerlich lacht sich halt und texten
und freundlich aus tirol vereint auch
sie hier
aber sich dann halt trotzdem mensch und
damit über was unser ziel überhaupt ist
so grundsätzlich dass ich so clausen
definieren beschweren mir geht es schon
viel geld hat phil collins kühl dass das
menschen wirtschaftlich stehen wir jetzt
gerade cent können der klimawandel
bekämpfen
aber es werden immer noch ein großes
mailbox und immer wieder wachstum auf
kosten und das ich aber gerade in damit
sie sich im moment glaube ich ist das
ganze
[Musik]
nina ist auf dem weg zu einer sitzung
mit dem rektor
sie geht ins gymnasium profil in
münchenbuchsee zu sechs dürfen sie dem
rektor ihre vorschläge präsentieren ihr
katalog islam
unter anderem fordern sie das schulhaus
nur noch auf maximal 21 grad zu heizen
und eine podiumsdiskussion zum
klimawandel veranstalten zu dürfen
auch den fleischkonsum in der mensa zu
reduzieren ist ihnen ein großes anliegen
und dann ist der koloss und
nachhaltigere wichtig darum geht es nur
noch da geht man genau dass das nicht
normal manager setzte definiert heißt
dass zwei gemein machen und sagen es
gibt eigentlich kein fleisch tag also
zweimal das muss umgekehrt
das tut not least sensibilisiert weil
ich kurz fleischmann ihm wird übel mache
und zwei gemeldete 50 einsätze und das
tut mir schon immer logisch sagt
visagist fleisch meine tür ist und wieso
ist jeder zweite wähler vorteil hat mir
doch sehr gut vorstellen werde das mit
ihm soll eigentlich auch dort aktiv wo
sie haben ich hoffe nicht dass es klug
nutzt natürlich rund ein drittel der
schülerinnen und schüler im profil
unterstützen die klimastreit bewegung
die überzeugten fleischesser wollen sich
nicht groß äußern
so die forderung dass es nur noch zwei
mal fleisch geben soll pro woche
unterstützt sie übrigens aufträge wie
halt vielleicht gehe ich mir ein herz
für den umgang mit der aktion ob ich mit
denen strom stütze das natürlich dass
diese aktiv sieht es demnach engagieren
mit yoga blog für prächtig
unterrichtszeiten und wenn der wenn die
dortige seit macher der dreifach
möglichkeit überhaupt er antwortete die
eigentlich heute für selbstverständlich
gehalten
tropisch oder nicht so realistisch jetzt
kann man den hauptakt haben uns
regelmäßig machen
die haie wahrscheinlich der
hauptangeklagte zum klarstellung aktiv
sind sind sie stehen ist die premier
league eine lösung ist noch nicht in
sicht
die delegation ist mit vielen anliegen
auf offene ohren gestoßen
aber es geht ihnen so wenig schnell so
gut dass man macht hat sich stimmig
sieht aber umsätze aber das ist auch so
oft das stadtmuseum ruhm nele hat
pauline zum abendessen eingeladen
beide essen kein fleisch zu hause haben
sie immer wieder diskussionen über den
klimaschutz angestoßen irgendwann kommt
ein punkt was der das realisierst
scheiße das ein geschäft was du machst
für die umwelt und für das album für die
zukunft und wenn du nicht vor scharfen
lanke denkt also man kann ich daran
gelegen die schuld gar nicht ab und sage
typische schlachter menschen haben und
nie genug danken wir schlacht das ist
was er macht das finden die halter sehr
cool
also für mich so dass ich sie übersehen
und mit denen merck aus batman twittert
und die ganz ganz viel bereits in vier
stufen
ich hoffe dass sich diese sind im
letzten frühling sind noch so viele
klagen und das würde mir äußert glaubst
normale player also ich finde das bier
floss
es gibt aus familien die schon mal
darauf dass auch für ab und sollte also
philosophische diskussionen mehr gehalt
und nick wird also über fleischkonsum
gerät
neles eltern haben kein problem damit
dass die jugendlichen für ihre anliegen
streiten ich finde heute einfach wenn
man streikt dann streikt
besteigt den muss man mit sanktionen
rechnen
darum steigt man strecke komplett an
praktisch allen schulen wird diskutiert
wie man die sanktionen für die schüler
streiks hand haben soll
das verspricht heute auch die klima
gruppe wie immer wird mit handzeichen
kommuniziert damit die
basisdemokratische sitzung gesittet und
nicht zu laut verläuft
technisch ist auch genau genau wann wir
treten die person macht so die zeit ist
so manfred hat den kupferpreis aber wie
der strafen für 1200 gs konstruktiv zu
sagen es langsam wieder ab samt und
sonders muss konkret sieht das
kompensieren und action die ganze sache
zu aber er weiß und zu wenig und dann
ist das miteinander machen so zwei drei
stunden unterricht so circa vorbereitet
für primar und sekundarschule zu
klimawandels weißt du das siehst du
stellst einem niveau das würde jetzt
bitte organisation gebissen oder so
für alle die ich finde es wichtig dass
wir das kompensieren und finden damit
voll okay will dann wären weder schwarze
jonas hat den job gefasst die vorschläge
dem rektor zu unterbreiten und dessen
strafe
in klimawandel wirklich so ganz basic
sowas ist der kleber worden
jetzt ist die komponente drehen und
macht die gerne sehen können für beide
und er dankt findet wo sich das weniger
getrauert sofort class anstatt also wie
wird denn wir auch community service so
zur wache und marina peter sich auf die
zwei listen aus arbeite mit mit ort um
das könnten wir zeigen mit kommt
parkring wie oft putz oder so sachen wie
sich zeigen wird beides machen
vielen dank
wenn die kurse
gemeinsam hat man sie später darauf
geeinigt dass die absenzen mit arbeiten
in der gemeinde kompensiert werden
können die dem klima zugute kommen
auch die berner malen transparente für
die demo in ihrer freizeit
selbstverständlich
die bewegung fordert keine kohle keine
gas und öl verbrennung mehr bis 2030 im
nationalrat kam letzten winter nicht mal
eine halbierung durch das wichtigste
schafft es ist wichtig dass die falls
ihre ziele nicht erreicht werden
wir fordern sie einen systemwandel was
genau verstehen sie darunter
die verschiedene von lehrlingen wasser
als sie stellen die vorlage des staates
sondern das ist klar
aufgabe für politik die schülerinnen und
schüler positionieren sich klar sie
wollen aus prinzip nicht mit parteien
zusammenarbeiten
der politisch links werkswagen problem
der politik ist ja dass politik geht
kompromiss über den klimawandel der
klimawandel mache jetzt kein kompromiss
aber sie sind nicht nur optimistisch
sehr pessimistisch und rangnick und die
ist sehr realistisch und sogar wie ein
krake chance die magnete gewesen damit
das schaffen
erstens tragen ist nicht ganz beendet
möchte dass angel negativen bewusst und
wird die andere optimismus ausgetragen
und es hilft mehr als global das gemüse
aus individuen mit leichter daheim
zukunftsplans
nena und pauline wenden etwa drei
stunden täglich für die klimabewegung
auf
sie sind unter anderem für die
medienarbeit zuständig und setzten sich
dadurch auch ziemlich aus der kriegs
flogen über folge und kritik und lob
aber souverän mit kritik um gleich am
anfang wird es schwierig ich bin halt so
also will ich ihn so an kein verständnis
dafür dass ich mich für politik im alter
in interessiert und ich halte was ich so
erbringen thema wie kann man sich ein
leben passieren wenn sie online
geschrieben wird oder ins gesicht gesagt
wer zu dass du dass du das ist auch
irgendwie falsch was du machst und das
schiller eh nicht verändere könne und
dass mir ja selber nicht machen fürs
klima also es wird davon ausgegangen
dass wir immer mit dem auto ins spiel
klar werde dass mir fast produkt benutze
das mir ist ein produkt kaufen sie nur
das klima und wir uns natürlich scheiße
und alles scheiße bauen das macht die
ganze jugendliche mit meiner kleidung
auf ein bisschen gelassener nehmen sie
es bereits und sie wehren sich speziell
wenn man ihnen vorwirft sie seien nicht
glaubwürdig nur weil sie ein handy
hätten wir wissen alle dass ohne handy
im zeitalter nicht mehr läuft und
zweitens sind wir alle sehr bewusst dass
mir keine neue hand ist kaufe second
hand von liedson brauche das übernahme
als mega oft kommen die stars mehr alle
ist ein echter handeln von amts wegen
muss auf die persönliche
lebensgeschichte
aber ich wäre nicht perfekten können wir
trotzdem die sache kritisieren dass mir
wichtig
im schulhaus profil ruft die klima
gruppe zur demo vom samstag auf
nicht alle sind feuer und flamme die
aktivistinnen und aktivisten sind in der
minderheit
wir brauchen gut mit und findet 3q
seiner mannschaft und ich wusste ja egal
was vielleicht lassen sich in der mensa
noch ein paar leute überzeugen
[Musik]
ja es ist damit wäre die konsequenz aber
wenn die nächste projekt normal aussieht
würde einer plastikplane schaut da eine
serviceaktion vor der emission weiter
vorn oder 100 klöster und der name
ausgeschlossen ich so und das heißt wir
politik machen das seht ihr unten aber
ich danke individuum machen warum
[Musik]
der tag der nationalen dem in wetzikon
macht sich jonas mit elaine auf den weg
[Musik]
hallo hallo
jetzt hat man in fragen der schüler in
bewegung sie und dann diene und lernen
die uns so und jetzt zeigt sich zeigen
wie große resonanz griechische
bevölkerung das mediale interesse an den
schülern ist groß vor allem jonas wurde
von den medien entdeckt er lebt im
moment praktisch nur für die bewegung
vor dass seine trittbretter und dadurch
meine richtige name bekannt und ja schon
die ein oder andere negative kommentare
oder finden muss man sagen dass du das
nicht bemerkt hat oder machen wir uns
nicht aber wir sprechen mit ihm zusammen
das lied geht wo auch durch aktivitäten
das habe reichlich auf dem radar und
besprechen mit dem und hoffe dass das es
gar nicht erst passiert
es ist schon länger spannungen
denn die mir friedliche sind
demonstriere mio kooperiere mit der
polizei die demos bewilligt und deswegen
war mit bald unbekannte randalierer da
drum landestrainer kampf pauline ist
noch beim brunch ihre schwester hat
nicht der frida mitgebracht und
patentante cordula ist aus berlin
angereist mutter an findet es gut dass
ihre tochter an die demo geht und sich
engagiert das ist nicht natürlich kann
ich kann nichts mehr schön beschäftigen
paulinas mutter war früher in der
anti-akw-bewegung
sie sieht ein paar unterschiede zur
klimabewegung heute vor allem forderung
stellten und mir haben redner und
rednerinnen und sind damit nun also die
einfach so entstanden
dem standen einnahmen liegen sind
mehrere seiten
noch zeigt können ein fall könnte das
schicke und zu testen
wir sind aber noch mal überdenkt das
wort geredet
ja auf jeden fall haben berlin er
empfinde das was man gar scheiße ich
dass mir finde es salaam frau rede und
dann erst auf wenn die sich neben halte
und dann soll ja aber vielleicht hätten
es nicht richtig kommuniziert mit fällig
sind also für die burg wollte drehte
sich auch erkennen wo das einfach so bei
uns gehört haben und dann haben wir
beide seiten sind
wir haben ein smiley auf der liste auch
pauli wird eine rede halten
in zwölf verschiedenen schweizer städten
gehen menschen auf die straße insgesamt
sind es rund 60.000 eine sonst die
jugendbewegung hat es seit den 80er
jahren nicht mehr geben
ich glaube dass wir auf irgend wie die
macher bei audiolith ascona
denn der sowie tv und free store bietet
die konzerne sind 70 prozent aller co2
emissionen verantwortlich
[Musik]
gazprom chef von bp shell und auf 97
weiter da macht es wenig sinn zu
behaupten mit unseren konsum behaupten
können wir die klimakrise überwinden
ja und jetzt werden die musik ganz das
motto we can dance
[Applaus]
[Musik]
neben hof geworfen
für jonas fanny und andré geht es nach
der demo ohne pause weiter
[Musik]
sie steht sie ruhig ich glaube das geht
es vielen die dritte zukunft könnten
ganze canyons in verbindung mit strauß
sie haben einen interview termin bei
radio eins
wenn damit die sandige zu direkt nach
der rede orbans tätig und mir sind prüf
und organisatoren im studio weiß in dir
ich bin 17 und kann die schülerin und ja
ich habe mal regelmäßig musik macht aber
jetzt ist der klima streik bin 17
aber kondition oberland und ich hab ja
das ist uns jetzt bin ich jetzt auch die
klima steig aus organisiert und war
dritter hallaschka während der demo das
geschäft von nike cornet also ich war
die allererste reth kalsow auf dem dank
mal was der theaterplatz und ich habe
sagt ruhig und ich weiß dass polizist
zeit hat ja hallo angetan das war
nedeljko loslaufen traum nicht blockiert
werden sich einfach alles pollex und
dann nur manche klagen widerlegen jahren
kontrolliert kann das bis acht personen
gekauft
das ist so ja das haben wir oft
unterschätzt hat man fordere gestellt
worauf die colts über beweist diese
nicht umgesetzt werden
die zahl sank die rendite instanz disco
sondern es gab es mir dass alle sehr
ideen mit dem letzten bericht vom
weltklimarat auseinandergesetzt und
jetzt zeigt hammond emissionen muss mit
20 50 arbeit bis zu 150 tanzkünste ganz
war global und schwyz ist industrieland
führen aber dass wir die ganz klare sich
wissenschaftlich vorgegangen und wir
sind da eben im gestocher dialog mit
klima micro schätzt die chancen dass das
passieren wird
wie groß ist jetzt die schätze studie
sieht es mir überlassen
also wenn die gegenfrage ist gerettet er
mit einem monat das wird durch die luft
ausgehen können
damit hätte das rennen vorstellen
ein schöner gedanke aber völlig
realitätsfremd und der fragliche theorie
somit realitätsfremde gedanken ob das
klug ist oder über händler müssten
realistisch
das gericht bekannt oder faktisch
während der krise und nehmen jetzt bis
mache der schulalltag geht weiter etwa
50 schülerinnen und schüler gehören wie
nele und pauline am bazar leonhard
gymnasium zum harten kern
die demo vom samstag hat den
jugendlichen auftrieb gegeben
ich glaube so schlimme minderheit dass
es gab inzwischen haben ist eben sagen
das ist jetzt gesprächsthemen dass das
ist dass wir uns bewegt und ich glaube
es wird uns jetzt alle bewusst dass das
gas ist wo jetzt bitte unsere of pop ist
für unsere generation
es ist ja vieles mehr in die hunderte
von nektar vielmehr was konsumiert hatte
in der mittagspause haben jetzt eben im
flugzeug geben
naturreis dass ich jetzt viel mehr thema
ort auf jeden fall und die schulleitung
hat bereits gehandelt
am leonhard gymnasium wird in zukunft
auf flugreisen verzichtet märz
vorgestellt abstimmen und damit ist von
seiner rolle etwas mutiger schaffen oder
stützen
einerseits und aus meiner schule
entschieden haben ist verboten sorge
sprach s und mehr aus schulen
entscheiden wo wir gerne mit dem motto
bereit
aber das sage ich die junge creme aktive
stehen und aktivistische rechberger
schuljahr dass hansi und das ist die
biologen tank es ist jetzt eine
persönliche petra vor jedem ist leichter
und man sehe da eine prozess- und und
dann entsprechen jetzt drin gott wird er
morgen die vitrine glas der von nina
lose also jetzt geht es dir jetzt auch
leisten und das ist immer schwieriger
bis 40
und ich habe mark erweisen ob das stimmt
aber dass man denn da die länger darf
dafür will halt reist viel länger wird
nämlich gerne zeit übernachten nach
budapest
das ist gut und das ist zu kommen und so
fahrer macht ja spaß
nele bringt ihr essen von zu hause mit
aber an einem gemütlichen lounge ist
nicht zu denken weil sie für die
medienarbeit zuständig ist musste die
vielen verschiedenen klimaschutz
regelmäßig bewirtschaften das schulhaus
hat einen eigenen staat für klima
anliegen
hier werden medienberichte filme und
politische inhalte geteilt und fragen
diskutiert 250 leute sind dabei mittwoch
haben wir sehen das kritisch
andere schüler sind für den kontakt zur
politik zuständig sie haben erreicht
dass der grosse rat in basel über eine
resolution von ihnen diskutiert das
klima notstandes wirft sieht
verantwortlich gemacht
die ganze bevölkerung klimawandels
informieren in zukunft prioritäten klima
schützen die stadt klimaschädliche
projekt setzt nach der cello stunde muss
pauline noch lernen und auch nele sollte
biologie befinden
die assoziation messen
ich mache schon weniger im moment
aber sie wird knapp mach einfach so ich
merke da unterscheiden wir aber sich
noch so können da wenig machen
jonas fravi und elaine sind in ihrer
freizeit wieder unterwegs diesmal zu
einem medien training in bern auch
kollegen aus der westschweiz sind dabei
es per jungtalent und klimaaktivisten
trio sie leitet das training also heute
der aufmacher beim sonntagsblick ist wie
grün ist jugend wirklich
und da ist natürlich die geschichte ganz
klar die den blick machen will also
eigentlich geht es darum ja ist das
schön und gut das gehen sie alle
demonstrieren aber was tun sie denn
wirklich
also man individualisiert ein thema was
eigentlich sehr spannend ist weil das
natürlich den ball komplett zu uns
zurück wird und wir dann eigentlich als
grande
also suchen trotz so ein bisschen
trotzig hinstellt also wir sind dann
plötzlich in der funktion wo wir sagen
müssen
ja wir wissen auch alle figuren und ich
gehe auch nie mit einem mit dem flugzeug
in die ferien
ich weise diese fragen werden dann das
werden wir weiter kommen sollen wir
einfach sagen wir antworten nicht mehr
und wir sagen wir wollen jetzt kein
interview über das thema geben oder wie
aus wien werden können wir dass das
lenken wie man es nicht zu allem eine
antwort geben oder sie gleich ablehnen
aber wir können auch zurückfragen ein
journalist des onlineportals trainiert
mit ihnen das interview vor der kamera
noch bis über immer schön zu mehr
willkommen
mit der zusage vorliegt wird kann man in
zürich aber auch die anderen städten
demonstriert hat das spricht antiquare
ganze bewegung jetzt ist er wieder
unterwegs andere idee muss machen
das sieht jetzt so was findet sie was
wäre also sagt sich und ist der 15
märz das wird dann aber ein großevent
dividenden sind wir wirklich
international sagte drews klar gesagt
nicht erwartet
mannschaft straßen fürs klima das ist
sicher nochmal risikos täglichem als
normal nach europa würde sagen haben wir
zum beispiel einflussnahme auf die
wahlen im herbst
das war mir eigentlich steht über london
sid wenn ich nur angestellt haben
herrscht ja sehr sekunden am markt aber
lecker und dann auf eine rede das
kartieren
sobald das mikro literatur und jetzt mit
hoffnungen und ist mit dem auto sondern
außerdem richtig laut
was sind die ist auch wurde jetzt vom
heutigen tag wird der preis auch wieder
gesagt meine kamera läuft so und so wie
dies mache ich glaube ich würde sich
anbieten dürfen wir schon alle steigern
sowie und ich kommen zur busse bedienen
nele wartet auf ihren kollegen kasimir
zusammen wollen sie an die nationale
klimastreit konferenz in bern
arbeitslos
rang
vor drei tagen hat der basler grosse rat
die resolution der bewegung deutlich
angenommen und für basel-stadt den klima
notstand erklärt nele ist glücklich
mega erfolg natürlich die oft wenig
chancen und haben mitgefiebert und
obwohl das klatschen
was haben diese klatsche was ist arno
handel ja es ist mekka das erfolg zu
landen ist aber immer noch leute dass es
nicht so ist es erreichen
die beiden sind die leiter sie wollten
ihre gruppen nicht hängen lassen und
haben deshalb den anfang der konferenz
verpasst
[Musik]
seit drei monaten investieren diese
jungen ihre energie vor allem in
klimaanlagen nele hätte schon ein paar
ideen was man aus dem klima notstand nun
machen könnte
wer sich so bray platz in basel
was man draußen etwas sehr gut da war
gratis öffentlichen verkehrsmittel
der flugschüler und der großen punkte
seien
netto co2 emissionen
im inland
so langsam die richtige schritt macht
wie immer läuft die kommunikation auf
hochtouren
ohne whatsup wäre die klimabewegung wohl
kaum so in schwung gekommen
später wieder wird's gut funktioniere
das problem ist darf an sie und deswegen
am anfang so sehr stolz so schnell diese
bewegt das war nicht
die menschen
von der heutigen konferenz werden sie
nicht mehr viel mitbekommen aber am
nächsten morgen um 10 stehen sie
gemeinsam mit 300 jugendlichen aus der
ganzen schweiz auf der matte nach
modernsten lern und arbeitsmethoden
beginnen die jungen den vollbepackten
tag mit entspannung
in gruppen diskutieren die schülerinnen
und schüler die unterschiedlichsten
themen aktion muss entsprach wie wäre es
mal nur halb stunden zu sagen es
basisdemokratische abläuft und im
konsens beruht
zwar ist er der prozess mehr steigen der
briefing es lohnt sich schlussendlich
entschädigung wird frau die kritisch und
des technikers nina nico pauline nele
fanny andrea lane jonas alle sind hier
alle sind motiviert
die positive gruppendynamik beflügelt
sie weiterzumachen
während er es gelungen ein reserviertes
mache um ihr werdet wieder in sich die
ehre
diesen vorteil will die man die reicht
werde zu stark und amica lebensgrundlage
und immer so lange machen bis meter
erreichen aber ich denke klar dass sich
ein politkrimi einfach wieder zeigt und
dass sie nicht fähig sind verantwortlich
verhält sich verschwinden in der schweiz
und ganz europa
[Musik]
[Applaus]